hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons ladies
and gentlemen this is the Tim Dylan
shall live from Austin Texas you are it
is not live we are in Austin Texas there
is no video for this episode why we are
in Austin Texas we have a studio being
built it is in the is it being built
fast enough who knows that's Ben's job
so if you are upset about no video Ben
Avery is good on Twitter and Instagram
DM him tell him what you think of how
long it has been taking in to get the
studio together but we do have a studio
it's in the process of being built okay
we're in Austin I'm doing cap city we
just left the mecca I still fit it's
surreal it still feels like an episode
of black mirror we just walked out of
Infowars mm-hm we did an hour with Alex
Jones this is something Ben's wanted to
do since he was a young child I mean
this is his Disney world watching Ben
walk around Infowars I was so happy
yeah and listened to every there's TVs
everywhere and all the shows they have
are just blaring and as Ben just walked
around in force looking for their coffee
and listening to their fish oil you know
the pills listening to the pitch for
their fish oil pills he was just like a
kid walking around the Magic Kingdom for
the first time it came up it came I
spoke to Rogen and I'm like I'm gonna be
down in Austin let's [ __ ] do it
Rogen set it up Alex you know we got
along famously as we would have imagined
but it was it was a [ __ ] wild thing
because we've watched the same thing
with Joe we started out watching the
shows and now we're on these shelves you
know there's something crazy about
watching a computer like what like I
said like a Boomer why do you want a
booter and then you get the chance
didn't I fainted huh
we started out denying shooting in our
living room and then we got the chance
to go de nom in nothing but it is a
[ __ ] wild when you're watching a
Macbook hmm and you're watching in fours
and then you climb through it and you
end up on the other side of the screen
it's gotta be nuts for you Ben it was I
I feel like Alex loved us first of all
which was great I was I was not like it
was a surreal experience but when he
walked into the room and we were sitting
behind the desk and we didn't know what
we were gonna talk about I was like
ready for it cuz I've seen his face so
many times I wasn't even fazed were you
pleased at all when he walked in here's
what phases me about the whole thing
right I uh I think about like God
willing
whatever I'm around in I don't know 10
years 20 years whatever the span of time
is where people are gonna look back on
this time you know like how we look back
on the financial crisis in 2009 like
people with everything right now we feel
like we're in it and and and we can't
look back on it like and it doesn't even
and and when you go through any time you
don't you can't imagine yourself looking
back on it but I try to think about like
years later somebody's gonna pick what
the [ __ ] was going on Donald Trump was
president there was this guy in Austin
Texas who created his own news network
and he [ __ ] got the platforms off
everything and then this other guy at a
podcast in California and it was like
the biggest [ __ ] thing and it's wild
that we have been able to see the inside
of a lot of those [ __ ] things other
than obviously the White House at Trump
right but you know it's it's pretty what
so to me it was just like interesting to
see that operation - I started listening
to Alex Jones I think
when he was in GCN which was up i may be
a Christian Network I'm talking about
the late 90s I would listen to him like
I'm talking about you know pre 911
listening to him what I think he was
railing against NAFTA and things like
that like he was always a populist and I
think he was he was definitely on a
network called GCN when I saw him today
yeah it was the genesis communications
network right and that was a long time
ago mhm and I imagine that's a Christian
network right yeah I think so yeah Ben's
like my parents love it it's on every
day at our house but that's when I start
with Alex and then like anything else
you know you come and go you wax and
wane
I went years without listening to him
and then then you know he'd pop up and I
listened to him again he'd come out with
a documentary and I'd watch it I
remember the Bohemian Grove documentary
came out I was like let's [ __ ] check
that out that's very interesting when
did you first get into Alex because when
I met you you were kind of and part of
you know we all here's a reality and I
said this to him today I will not back
off from this he is the most
entertaining person on the planet you
know he really is like what whether you
like him or not or whether you you think
he's the devil or not he the guy is
[ __ ] transfixing to just watch I
broadcast it for years I've done
stand-up for years I've been an actor
when I was a little kid now I've been on
stage since I'm six being in a room with
the guy he is a [ __ ] performer and
he's just when he is at his best and
today we probably got just a small
percentage of them cuz we've all seen
him when he's firing on all cylinders I
mean that second Rogen was wild yeah
when did you first get into I when I got
really deep and Alex it's when he was
getting banned that's when I got really
really deep so when did you first come
across him I think when I think when I
was living in Texas for sure I knew of
him but I didn't even think of him as
like a like a a guy who was super I
don't know how how do people perceive
Alex in like 2010 I can't even really
remember now because I think
when I remember him and I remember is
when he was promoted loose change he was
promoting that documentary and he was
showing up to 9/11 events with the
bullhorn and talking about you know
George Bush and the Carlyle Group and
9/11 and trying to get you know
information out there and I remember
that Alex Jones who was loathed
by conservatives they hated Alex Jones
like hated him like he would say you
know it's a mate and again we're talking
ten years ago and and everything's
flipped because conservatives even
Democrats liberals did not like him he
was liked by a very small group of
people and now I've seen questioning
9/11 kind of go mainstream
I wouldn't say mainstream but it's a lot
more acceptable now especially in light
of Epstein and all these things you play
like yeah we don't forget I have a joke
in my act now where I go nothing will
shock you anymore after I've seen like
if you find out tomorrow if they're like
9/11 ever happened that Twin Towers are
still there
you'd be online somewhere and you'd be
like the [ __ ] media you know like you
wouldn't even be shot it's a joke in my
act where I'm like yeah [ __ ] media
come on anybody the twin towers are
still [ __ ] there in New York do you
believe that God if there's not I mean
there's nothing that'll move you off the
you know you'll still stand in line you
won't get out of line hmm
you will not get out of line wherever
you are Whataburger whatever you're not
getting out of that line
for 9/11 ever happened if they go by the
way our bad our mistake we didn't really
mean to we didn't mean to buildings fell
that we we were but I remember that Alex
Jones and then then you know when Obama
gets elected he becomes more of a
right-wing populist by the very nature
if he's an anti-establishment guy and
he's always talking about who's at the
top so it was Bush then it was Obama
what is fascinating is when he became a
fan of Trump you saw the whole dynamic
of Alex Joe
change because instead of being a guy
that was outside of the establishment no
matter who was in it right or left he
became a guy that you know openly
supported Trump and also because I never
remember him being political when I was
growing up listening to him I would tune
in and it was like we're all were all
being lied to you were all being
manipulated he talked about FEMA you
talk about mass graves and then he got
on the trumped ranks he hated he loathed
Hillary Clinton and and Trump was this
you know populist or fake populist
whatever you think and and then Alex you
know had him on the show he had Trump on
the shelf famously and then that's when
I think he people started to see him
differently because they're like oh
here's this guy who was just this
anti-establishment guy who's now picked
the side now he's a cheerleader for
Donald Trump if you remember the bushes
the Clintons all of Hollywood all of the
media pretty much now the media helped
build Trump's candidacy by just the
spectacle of it of course but most
people in the media didn't want him to
win I think Rupert Murdoch didn't even
want him to win I think that the
majority of CEOs in the country not all
of them but a lot of them did not want
Trump to win and they had valid reasons
for that like this he was a wrecking
ball and and Alex got behind him and had
him on the show and that's when I think
it was very interesting to see how Alex
became a different kind of figure to
many people and then of course the Sandy
Hook stuff which I only started knowing
about when it was when it would because
I didn't watch him then I wasn't
watching him when that was happening
right so I we I only got the fallout
from it so I don't know what he did I
know he said some things he regretted
and and then people did horrible things
to the families of the Sandy Hook kids
that died unforgivable things criminal
things things I will not justify things
I don't think Alex would ever justify
and me being on that network doesn't
condone that doesn't excuse that
in any way but what I think happened at
that point was that you saw big tak just
like I think the term is like it's more
than even D platform like unperson him
like they took away every opportunity he
had to broadcast to put himself out
there they took away all his social
media I think even his bank accounts
were getting canceled I mean it was
pretty wild to watch and again not
excusing anything that he said or that
but again what he actually said and then
what's been put out there that he said
might be different I think he did say
you're responsible things things he
should not have said but just the idea
of you know this Swift and complete
complete the platforming of this guy off
every single social media platform and
also restricting his money to earn and
restricting his ability to earn an
income from any of the places where he
was previously earning an income
happened overnight pretty immediately
and it would I don't think there was
really a warning for it it just it was
just like the the gods a big tak came
down and said this is over and and then
you started looking into him and that's
when you got in a woman then what what
but now that I think about it this is
really funny the when I first got into
Alex was when I first got into comedy
and when I first got into comedy I got
into Patrice and Hicks and Stanhope and
I found that clip of Stanhope bringing
Patrice onstage at cap city because
York's on stage you come from really
Christian family yeah so when you when
you you see you get into the guys who
were like questioning all of everything
right exactly and so I found that
Patrice O'Neal interview on Alex Jones
back in like oh five or whatever I'm
like this is really interesting it was
like what's the bilderbergs what are
what's the Bohemian Grove and that was
kind of how I got in the door with all
that stuff and then but then many tv5
kids out that's the song you're gonna
sing what who were the Bilderberg
what's the Bohemian Grove the wheels the
rothschilds go to the park and they
worship an owl named Moloch it's not an
owl it's of whatever right fans all
biblical he knows what it is what is
Moloch actually Moloch is it's the calf
it sacrificed his children but it's like
a yeah Canaanite thought yeah it's not a
now so you get into not it was I because
believe me Grove it's a now they see the
almalik but it's not an alibi ever
it's a veil but my point is that that I
was introduced to Alex as a as a
comedian he is he's an entertainer he
was always to me just a funny guy like
I'm with you I didn't think of him as a
politician and then I stopped paying
attention to him because you know I had
a life and I had no idea about the Sandy
Hook stuff until way later when all the
repercussions started coming down so
right yeah what was it like when I told
you we were gonna do it I would have
loved to surprise you here's the thing I
would have loved see here's what I
should have done I thought about okay
what I should have done is just take you
to cap city tell you that we weren't
like I just need you to film a shat I
need to record a podcast name here and
then when we land go right there
and had you had no clue I would have
blacked out
see here's what I was afraid of
literally the reason I didn't do that is
because I was afraid of that
yeah I said to myself I don't know I
knew there was a good chance he would
get on tonight mm-hmm I wanted you to
get on but I also knew that it would be
completely unfair to just throw you on
the Infowars set right cuz this is your
wedding present you know I mean I'm
grieving but this is your wedding
practice I was gonna get you Alex Jones
I was gonna get one in four words for
your weddings your two years sobriety
anniversary you get to go to Infowars by
the way I what you know I said today on
the show I looked at him and I went I
would look to Alex and when I think
you're rational
guy he said he's a moderate oh you're a
moderate which but but by the way in its
in his world he kind of is like he
doesn't want a white ethnos stage he
doesn't wan he just believes in
pedophile cults and lizard people that's
what I believe in I think I think we're
moderates I do
I'll entertain different arguments about
health care sure have Medicare for all
but don't come and tell me the plan it's
not run by a small group of people
through blackmail and murder each other
I'll have none of that don't tell me
that so I is a moderate but I couldn't
do that to you because I just didn't
want you to like [ __ ] and fall down and
the yeah I only space that once at the
very end at the very end I had no idea
we're gonna have to watch your back I
don't know what he was saying you kind
of lost track of what he was saying at
some point well cuz he's so good he's
such an amazing broadcaster and he's so
entertaining and he can speak
extemporaneously for Lauren which is by
the way how he gets in trouble
hmm that's how he gets in trouble and
it's how I would get in trouble it's how
anyone gets in trouble because you speak
extemporaneously mean off the top of
your head for a long time and you are
not relying on a teleprompter and
nobody's got cue cards and there's no
plan and there's just a couple of
articles and you're riffing comics call
it riffing you're just going off the
dome and you're in the conspiracy space
like you're talking about [ __ ] things
you can't may or may not be true how do
you not get in [ __ ] trouble you're
gonna get in trouble all I've gotten in
trouble like I've said things and then
look back at one yeah I shouldn't have
said that but that's what it is there's
no [ __ ] way you make it you know yeah
we were even sitting in the green room
and they were broadcasting that one guy
who was just like some webcam guy they
have any talking about the Richmond
Virginia in the Richmond Virginia free
speech rally which is gonna probably
turn into some type of bloodbath yeah I
mean it's supposedly gonna be you know
and they're like there's gonna be some
you know probably it's gonna be some you
know whether it's leftist they were
worried about antiphon whatever they
said like or
a quintel pro-style operation they're
gonna be agitators they feel like it the
free speech rally there's like there's
gotta be some agitators and then they're
like and by the way there's gonna be
some people that listen they just
believe that we can't vote our way out
of the problem and we don't want to salt
those people but they're gonna be there
with their weapons and they believe we
can't vote our way out yeah so and me
better sitting in the green room as is
going on go what the [ __ ]
and then he signs off he goes okay I'm
signing off and by the way we have none
of the facts so far but we have to keep
talking about this regardless yeah this
is not Alex it's another girl there's
none of any of the facts but this is
it's the story and we got to keep going
with it
God just go with it hey everybody it's
another bachelor podcast it's 2020 and
there's a lot going on we're in the
brink World War two Australia's engulfed
in flames there's impe see these kids
have tried to write a ad in my voice for
The Bachelor podcast that we talked
about what they don't realize is that
I'm a comic genius and they are not so
it would be like me writing a workout
plan for a professional athlete okay but
I'll read it anyway okay because I'm
sure that they're the real geniuses it's
just because of some mistake I'm the one
that people care about anyway let's read
the copy you know it's just the way it
worked out we're just as funny as that
guy it just shook out the wrong way
there's an impeachment trial coming up
but the world is being sucked off it's
mana
but there's nothing more important going
on right now that season 24 of ABC's The
Bachelor if you're listening to my
podcast you're obviously a fan of that
program you're probably tuning in every
week but you're wasting your [ __ ]
time if you're not listening to a
Bachelor companion podcast the best one
out there we've talked about it before
it's another Bachelor podcast featuring
Nick with schizophrenic parents who
produces the Elven show Dylan who's
Jewish and Pat who's an older man after
hearing yet read I did last week Pat as
I assumed he might in your future
attempted to take his own life while he
is independently wealthy with a child on
the way my words called into question
his reason for doing another Bachelor
podcast after
you contemplative glasses of Pinot
Grigio there too wording these kids he
naturally started asking more dangerous
and dark questions of himself what's the
point of being a father if you know
you'll fail what's the point of doing
anything really what's the point of even
sticking around he's found that a
bathtub by his podcast buddies who
resuscitated him with the news that the
ad read I did last week was in fact did
in fact move the numbers he's now in a
better place mentally not in heaven so
tune in here's what I'll say about these
kids they're really giving it a shot
give it a shot if you watch The Bachelor
and you want a companion podcast if you
watch The Bachelor everyone listens to a
podcast whether it's Jared free the
girl's gotta eat or [ __ ] he you know
you know Jewish women talk about the
gash whatever it is it's you know rich
white Jewish women talk about the gash
which is the biggest type of podcasting
right now you if you are a lonely a
woman living in a city who doesn't
celebrate Christmas and you want to talk
about you want to talk about flicking
your beam you were making a trillion
dollars a year
and so I'm supporting these three white
three white fox for getting involved in
this three white men okay I wish they
were good-looking but I've seen one of
the minutes it ain't great tune in every
week to another bachelor podcast on
iTunes YouTube and Spotify remit he's
not deformed Nick right he's not that
bad-looking he's I wouldn't say fine but
remember everyone escapism is the only
thing that matters right now I'm kidding
Nick we're kidding it's comedy relaxed
I'm sure you'll find out does he have a
girlfriend
you'll find when Nick you're making good
money you'll find a nice lady and you
guys can go live out in the valley and
scare and you could and you could record
each other there is nothing you can do
to prevent us from annihilation the only
thing you could do is find ways to cope
but I can't think of a better way than
listening to another Bachelor podcast
farther than their spin-off recapping
play see I want to talk about here's the
thing about below-deck I would come on
that show and talk about below deck with
you guys because so they have another
spin-off show recapping Provost hit
series below deck another below deck
podcasts also available here's the thing
I'm kind of interested in talking about
below deck and I am a superior comedian
and broadcaster to you and it's not even
close
that we're not even in the same realm of
anything like I shouldn't even note we
should never have even met each other we
should never have been in the same
room milah [ __ ] I've been doing this
since I'm six years old okay regaling
crowds all across the country with great
[ __ ] theatrical stage presence
I had a great voice then and I and I
could tap dance so the point is I
shouldn't even we shouldn't even you
should only know me through the press
but the fact is I will come on your
below-deck shitty podcast because that
show fascinates me because I'd like to
watch it I don't know why I just leave
it on for hours at a time and I just
kind of stared it I don't care about
anybody on it or if the boat crashes or
anything I but there's something about
it well I don't know it's just kind of
interests me so I'd be willing to come
on that if you want me to come on you
have an open invitation to invite me on
through Ben don't speak to me directly
don't DM me directly you out of your
[ __ ] mind but through my people
contact me try to get contact try to get
in contact with me okay
or have me back on Theo sure I know he's
interviewing Tommy Lehren okay I don't
know who's he got next week Hitler have
me on the program again please thank you
I know we did the last time with Logan
Paul this time we'll do it with a big
tick tock star how about this time we do
with a little hoodie
chase Hudson he is little hottie he owns
the hype house kids [ __ ] figured it
out he's got nine million father he's
dating Charlie D'Amelio who's [ __ ]
the biggest tick tock person but you
know what I think tick tock Smisek fat
Irish guys who think that immigration is
a legitimate issue that's what tic TOCs
missing but it'll be there in a few
years you're racist ant is joining
tick-tock so don't worry about it
well get famous while you can because
you're racist Hannah's joining this has
nothing to do with you anymore
just watch The Bachelor podcast give
these kids a chance maybe they're funny
and I'm sure they've got a lot to say
about me maybe like dan tam that he-man
fauna and Dylan whose parents are Jewish
I don't know why they threw that and cuz
because because we're supposed to think
that he's but we're struggling Dylan
Dylan the Jew I can't believe it
good for you Dylan alright folks good
luck Oblast goodbye right we had no idea
what was going to happen before we got
but by the way that's when I thrive I
think that's when Alex tribes I I mean
when we start planning things get
[ __ ] haywire like I I get excited
when there's just the open wide open and
I feel like you maneuver pretty well
with some of the thanks thrown your way
yeah I did the best I could
now there's interesting it was kind of a
dark energy in the building and I don't
but Alex doesn't have it but the workers
do yeah because they're pretty like he
did you like he may have it if you spent
more time around it but he actually was
just like a lovely guy to us just like a
friendly funny nice guy but the workers
seemed that because the day in and day
out like I mean Rogan talked about it
all the time I'm like I could not do day
in and day out what they do like to just
talk about politics every day um you
know no matter what side of the of the
coin you're on no matter but there's a
darkness they're all kind of afraid of
him you know cuz I'm sure he lets him
have it every now and then he it seems
like he would every now and then would
just let him half and we saw a glimpse
of it we saw a little bit of it so a
little bit of it but it probably gets
when there are no guests in the building
it's probably like that scene in
succession I don't know if anyone's
watching where they do poor on the floor
and the head character in succession
who's supposed to be like Rupert Murdoch
who just want to call the globe
his name's escaping right now he's
[ __ ] brilliant Brian who's a guy in
succession
they had a succession but he goes he
goes bar on the front doors get on the
floor get on the floor and he just it's
a like a party in the show succession
and he just starts stuffing hotdogs
Brian Cox Brian Cox is amazing it's a
great scene well worth a watch there on
the floor and he starts stuffing hot
dogs in their mouth he goes hey little
piggies you want it and he starts
throwing the hot dogs on the floor and
they have to pick them up with their
with their bells and it goes you like
your little piggies bar on the floor
Colin oh that might go down here 10
minutes after me and Ben leave if they
don't [ __ ] do the right yeah yeah
yeah
you know like but there's a dark energy
there what do you
beat that too I mean other than the fact
that it's like the topics that they
taught in there they're on the outside
everything is very large though war is
come like we land that we're walking
around awesome and I lost as everyone I
was looking at people I was like do you
know where the prison planet is we're
trying to find and we're trying to find
the prison planet there is a war on for
your mind hmm
when we walked into the green room it's
it's 50 degrees in there it's ice freeze
freezing cold first thing I said to you
as I said this fills weirdly like a
government building right yeah it does
it's it's and that's where you probably
get conspiracies that go Alex as part of
that whatever I it's you know which I
don't believe but it is a operation that
is larger in scope than you would
imagine
he's you know God several studios it's
it's in news what he started with in
he's one guy I mean and there's other
people on that network that are gaining
in popularity but he's still the guy and
so everything's an outgrowth of him and
so the idea is pretty amazing we're
living in a pretty interesting time in
history where one guy can get a
following that dwarfs a mainstream media
news outlet hmm like he can have more
people following him and watching his
content then the Evening News then you
know a network news show that is and
that was interesting to see up close
like that was interesting to see how
that happens that being said yeah there
is it just a dark energy there there is
like we're on the edge of you know every
single thing they talk about is that
we're in a war we were in the midst of a
war and we're on the edge of something
terrible happening and you feel it you
feel with all the music they play da da
da you know and everybody kind of has
that feeling in the studio and then of
course all of them it's in an
undisclosed location in Austin because
they're all you know everybody's like
I'm sure they get threats and they have
DDoS attacks right and all that stuff
like the site suffers a lot it's wild
and then as we leave there's just two
little kids like eating chick-fil-a and
then one of the break rooms and I don't
even know I guess
someone's kids are like chick-fil-a
breakroom yeah yeah what would be
hilarious is if we let those two little
kids got on and they were like MK ULTRA
is ripped like you know they just
started going off you know they just
they put they both take out their guns
like don't [ __ ] you're not taking my gun
you know they're being interviewed by
gun girl what's her name that's what I
thought they're gonna put like
afterwards they were like you want to do
some other shows I'm like we gotta run
yeah we gotta run
you know Alex Alex doesn't really get
comedy but he's the funniest guy ever
yeah I don't think yeah I don't think he
gets we played some more sketches on the
show I'm sure his people enjoy I don't
know that he I think he liked some of it
I bet these heads run in a million miles
a minute and I bet that there's parts of
it that he doesn't like he found the
Greta thumb burg sketch what we did we
probably play her agent he found that
interesting because he felt like he's
like yeah that's an accurate depiction
of an agent he's like you're not even
he's like you're not even to a comedy
you're just wrong people what it is
you're just tell me what it is I've seen
Sam plays walking around LA this is real
you are making McCain nothing's funny
here this is what it is
I'm like thank well thank you I mean he
said a couple of things that are just
not true
I bloody know I don't listen cuz that's
the other thing on the show where you
have to be careful because you're
sitting there and you're nodding and
you're agreeing with them about
everything right and this is literally
what happened word-for-word he's I can
free speech is important when we started
the country we know we had Fred and
Michelle wolf bragged about killing her
baby she said it made her feel strong
and I'm like whoa hold on
I don't know that did that have a dope I
got a and he's a jerk horse is a Nazi
he's literally not so you have to stop
yourself because you're going like yeah
yeah then you're like oh hold on hold on
wait a minute only because I've not I
don't I know so little about George
Soros I know I know what people know hmm
which is that he's a financier he's
collapsed a few world economies like
anyone else with his level of wealth and
he takes an interest in how people live
and what they do any funds the people
that he think I mean it's like but I
know that he's a boogie man on the left
in the same way that the coach of the
boogie man further I
right but I don't I know nothin about
George roses histories so when somebody
goes he's a Nazi
I'm like goin is even on a basic level
like off air he's like yeah copyrights
and stuff we can play whatever we want
there's no such thing as copyright so
doesn't is this right Alex that's not
maybe I don't know I mean who knows well
I guess I might believe in the
Illuminati too if every single major
company got together and D platformed me
on the same day
yeah well listen he is the monastic the
world that has happened in a sense
because like he 100% is not wrong when
he talks about a small group of elite
people controlling the world and all
those resources nobody really debates
that that the debates are like well what
are we gonna the debates are what if
that wasn't the case what would it look
like would it be one dictator doing it
would it be worse would it be some
global government system I mean it's
like the real thing is okay well then
what comes next it's really like I
compared to what argument most people
and most people even cynical people like
myself will kind of be like yeah it is
bad I hate private prisons I hate this I
hate that but then it's like when you
when you people like well let's tear it
all down you're like well great but then
what mm-hmm
so he's not wrong about that I think
what's happened to him though is it's
become explicitly political like it
feels very political as of late and it
feels like Republicans good Democrats
bad Trump good when any distance himself
from that today a little bit but Trump's
good Democrats are bad and it's just
interesting that this guy Donald Trump
we know has been with these people
admittedly been bribing these people
pouring money in their mouths getting
everything he wants from them hanging
out with Kasich to everything that this
guy is somehow the the white knight
savior of the country that's just to me
I've always found that hard to believe
I'm just a cynical guy and I don't
believe that Donald Trump is gonna do it
I don't believe that Jesus Christ chose
Donald Trump too but there are people
out there to believe that I'm not saying
the Trump's Hitler I don't believe that
either
I believe Vladimir Putin put Trump in
your breakfast cereal or whatever
people on the other side allege hey I
think Trump's just a guy I I think he's
he's a he's a statement that it isn't
working and we're probably at peak of
what this is gonna look like in terms of
you know the economy's roaring and
things are pretty good and I think a
Donald Trump like figure comes around
after 20 years of a government that's
been mired in corruption and has sold
out the middle class to say nothing of
the poor and that's when a figure like
Trump emerges it's when a figure would
emerge that you know that's like [ __ ]
everything but it just feels Alex it
feels more like a political show now
that a conspiracy show but now those
worlds have fused together and on the
Left they fuse together because they
believe that Russia was behind
everything
tulsi gabbard Russia everybody's Russia
you know Bernie a war in every every
single but what was it like for you
interacting with him because he was
calling you Ed McMahon because you
weren't talking that much yeah he was
like who's a guy who's a guy that sat on
the couch next to Carson didn't say
anything man Sooey is Ed McMahon I was
how wild is it to out shows reading your
Twitter Twitter handle I know that every
is good it's so real what is it like
interacting with him it was just the
thrill of a lifetime dude he's just I
mean is there anybody more the whole
time after in between every break Tim
and between every break we would just we
would just turn to each other and we'd
be like how much fun is this I mean have
you had more fun than that than doing
him I mean that was it was such a
[ __ ] it was so much fun
um I have had more fun okay I have more
fun to do in fact I've not had more fun
than good for you well that's lovely if
your fiance to here but III I've had
more fun but I loved it it was a lot of
fun it was amazing
he's an interesting guy he's a
fascinating guy the operation is
fascinating it's a fascinating period of
history to see up close this wasn't
something that could happen
years ago you a guy could not amass the
following that he has without the
technology probably without the
political climate that we're in like he
is again it's a perfect time capsule to
look at you know you look at Rogan and
the success Rogen's had and it's like
again these guys are really markers that
you you know if you were like you know
you ever see a tailor who's who's fixing
a suit who's altering a suit and they
make markers with the chalk on the suit
and to what they have to do you would
make one by Rogen you'd make one by Alex
cut leg and not that they're related but
that like they are media operations that
primarily center around one guy and
they're as influential as huge networks
it's wild it's very interesting I kind
of had a I had a private thought on the
during the interview I thought I wonder
if Donald Trump is watching did you have
that thought at all while we were
broadcasting no but it's not a
unreasonable thought maybe trumple like
that I think Trump and Alex speak III
think it's very possible Trump has done
Infowars he might be why it's very
possible Trump somebody showed him the
Megan McCain sketch I'm not positive
that that's happened
hmm but I wouldn't matter I mean if
[ __ ] Trump does rogue and wrote and
we'll play it for him I know that God
bless Joe he'll [ __ ] he'll be like
listen
seems old irregular came but yet I'm
making Alex laugh I got one big laugh on
the show that that just made my wolves
[ __ ] like yeah yeah yeah we won't
ruin it from yeah you have to watch
watch calm yeah I don't know how anyone
will be able to watch people who said
how were can we see this I'm like I
genuinely don't know I'm sorry what I'm
going to do guys is I'm going to clip it
and put it in a Dropbox link and just
put a link on the patreon or something
yeah because we can't [ __ ] around
YouTube we can't lose our YouTube
channel we can't start putting clips on
Instagram can we put clips on Twitter
well yeah I think it should be fine
actually cuz Logan Paul and all those
guys have Alex Jones on count dank EULA
had Alex Jones on a lot of the youtubers
are having them on his channel I know
but I think that
different having him on your channel is
different than clipping his show and
putting it out
oh you're riot cuz it's not supposed to
be on there yeah you're right
that's I think the big difference yeah
we shouldn't clip anything and put it
anywhere I would not I'll do a dropbox
dropbox dropbox League on the patreon
pay the money folks you want to be in
the club pay the [ __ ] money yeah you
know I don't know what to tell you it's
a big club and you and I can be in it
for $5.00 a month that should be the
start of the show we should have that
Carlin quote it's a big club and you and
I can be in it for $5.00 a month it's
not that bad you can watch Timmy and
been on Infowars making his dream come
true in Austin supportive of the Tim
Dylan show comes from manscape the best
in below-the-belt men's grooming okay
this is for your pubic hair manscape
this precision tools for your family
jewels don't use the same trimmer on
your face as you're using on your balls
you dummy
that's gross get the manscaped perfect
package 2.0 this set has everything you
need to keep your tree trimmed there are
so many [ __ ] this head has so many
different like keep your tree trimmed
tools for you Jules
God it's called the lawn mower 2.0
because it has proprietary advanced skin
safe technology so this trimmer won't
Nick or snag your nuts it's also
waterproof so you could use it in the
shower get your stocking stuffer looking
and smelling its best with perfect
package 2.0 this comes with the razor
plus a crop preserver an anti chafing
Bowl deodorant moisturizer you ever you
already put deodorant on your armpits
why not put deodorant on your balls
they're also throwing in the crop
Reviver this will be keeping your balls
from sweating or sticking I mean there's
a deal you need one of these things
there's only a few of them on the market
ones in your elico body groom the other
one is this this helps out the show okay
if you liked the show and you need to
shave your balls man or woman cuz it's
2020 if you're a woman and you have a
penis and you need to shave
this this is also the way to go so you
get 20% off and free shipping with code
T I am use the code use the code so
people know that you're coming from this
podcast 20% off and free shipping with
the code T I am 20% off you're not gonna
get the deal if you don't use the code T
IME get free shipping okay and you will
get this [ __ ] really cool thing I use
it they sent me one for free that is
very easy to use you're not worrying
about cutting your dick off you're not
worrying about some horrible accident
they've taken a lot of care with the way
they put this thing together you can use
it you can use it while you're
intoxicated you can do it while you're
driving you can do it while you're
operating heavy machinery if you're
flying a plane you can do it you can do
it in public because it's very discreet
so you're not gonna Nick yourself and
yell and then everyone's gonna turn
around and the Wendy's and realize you
have your dick out just be quiet you can
sit in the back booth of a Pizza Hut and
just trim yourself very quietly they
might not even care if they notice you
there's never more than two or three
booths occupied in a Pizza Hut that's
one of the laws gravity is one of the
laws and the other laws and in a Pizza
Hut there's just two or three boots two
and three unfortunate families that's it
and you can just sit in a dark corner of
the restaurant get yourself together
if use the promo code okay we're gonna
say the promo code again because many of
you have many many issues the promo code
is T I am like my name it is my name T I
am your 20% off and free shipping with
the code t IM at manscaped comm to go to
manscape comm t IM 20% off free shipping
if your dude you need this that's a
simple reality you don't need everything
we sell but you need one of these and
this is a lot better than the norelco
body groom and i don't know what else is
on the market for this but this is the
way to do it
so again manscape comm 20% off t I am
a real interesting energy in that
building man just walking around
everybody's real caffeinated probably
mm-hmm you know tons of editors just
sitting there dead I'd I tried to talk
to some of them they were like scared
did you try to talk to anybody they like
jump no I didn't try to talk to anybody
I just went to the bathroom twice and
then went back to the green room and I
didn't really try to stop but there was
a few people on the Instagram post were
like I work for Alex I'd no idea you'd
be there um what did you try to say to
the editor you just I just said hello to
them and they were like terrified and
they went back to their work yeah that's
what I did I was just like hello I think
they're afraid that if they're caught
fraternizing with people and not working
they're in real trouble okay okay how do
you get hired on that network
I think they poked by the way I think
they post like a secret I think they let
you know in the job description that
it's gonna come with some you know yeah
I don't know if it's on like but III
they do they hire people they need to
get people so I but I do think I read
some article about it from some
disgruntled employee that didn't like it
and wrote an article than your times
wrote an article somebody wrote an
article about this guy and he was I
think talking about how he got the job I
either read it there or somewhere else
and they were like it's kind of this
highly secretive thing where they figure
out and then they kind of let you in on
the fact that like yeah this is you know
this has downsides being associated with
our outfit has downsides and like we
will be honest with you this this comes
with some baggage there will be some
baggage to work in here some people just
editors yeah we thought about that we
said I wonder what how much people make
yeah I wonder how much Owen makes and
those guys I think we're who's the other
guy he's like the protege yeah we saw
him Rex you saw her I did not see him
yeah we didn't get to see the whole time
these people are Ben's like there's oh
and I'm like oh what Ben knows all these
people yeah I know gun girl yeah I
didn't see her but you saw Owen I didn't
see you and I
Rex is the browser son who's like he's
like he's a real protege yes
right yeah he was in the tank with Alex
the other day they have like a tank they
drive around into Austin now they have a
tank yeah it's like this big like tank
car like armored car thing and they just
shout Alex was just shouting through a
bullhorn that like you know Hillary
Clinton slits the throats of children
well that's what we said don't give him
our line that's what we said in our
video what with it we did that where
does they put that content out they were
live-streaming that on Rex Jones
periscope on Twitter because every other
outlet they're like banned from how
great would be of wreck shelters just
huge on tik-tok he's just dancing around
like pointing to things doing the cowboy
boogie yeah he's like Hillary Clinton's
a vampire you just points to it need to
dancer that doe she got song you mom man
I'm not you know what I take talk but I
don't know man it was it was a kind of
interesting it was a really really
interesting [ __ ] day I didn't think I
didn't know what it was gonna be like it
went as well as it could have gone I was
very pleasantly surprised by everything
I knew it would go well he's a friendly
[ __ ] dude you know do you think he
retires do you think he keeps going do
you think
four more years and then he's done do
you think he'll I mean this is sort of a
dark thing to say but I think he's kind
of a guy that just sort of drops one day
so he just goes to the end I guess
interesting yeah he just goes and rides
it out until the end and he just keeps
going it's very possible he's just he
lives hard he'd I will say he looks a
little better now he seems sober yeah I
think he stopped drinking he's starting
to get him something together lose a
little weight you know I mean good for
him man you know but it's it's wild to
think about you know what's the next
iteration of him I wonder if there is
one like if Trump is out in four years
and then a Democrat gets back in or
Democrat like well I wonder what then he
becomes the outsider again where he
doesn't really have the access but I
think at that point he retires maybe I
think you gotta retire you can't see
someone filling those shoes he's just a
one of a kind guy yeah and a lot of
people would be happy that nobody's
filling their shoes
probably well like Paul Joseph Watson or
any of these guys they can't even come
close not as what the gravitas number is
entertaining none of them are is wild
none of them errs but I do think that
nothing lasts forever and then you know
there will be people that will step into
that role
you just don't know who they are gonna
be I could never dude I could never
spend every single day just talking
about politics at like we talked about
conspiracies a fair amount but we're
always trying to be funny and that's why
I'm a comedian so just wanna I want to
make people laugh I want to meet people
happy and I could just never whether it
was fox or CNN or info war any of these
no matter what the outfit was I could
just never spend all day every single
day just in like this [ __ ] lick on
war footing yeah you've said it before
dude but you couldn't get paid enough
money to keep your mouth shut anyway you
know
yeah well though yeah sure but I don't
know if in fours I'd have to keep my
mouth shut I think I'd be allowed to say
whatever I want they would hire me I
think they would hire me yeah that's the
other thing I had that thought today
like oh I could work here I had that
thought we were in now it's Jones this
place I'm like I could get a job here
just have a show here probably I mean I
could be wrong but I don't think I'm
wrong you could - you could be my editor
and we could just go there and work I
mean that's how crazy we're not going
we're not connected we're not going to
but just that was a thought in my head
like I was just like oh all the
different ways this thing could go you
know all the different ways nominee
could go I could be I could get a show
here talking about fluoride in the water
yeah and just start doing that yeah you
know in the same way a lot of these
comics went full sjw like all they do
you know they put out more content of
them canvassing for Bernie Sanders
then they put out of them being funny
you know yeah so what's interesting to
me but it's like you can just you could
just end up in a place where you
wouldn't think I wouldn't think when I
started comedy I didn't think I was
gonna be an Alex Jones Show now it's
stupid knowing me knowing my personality
I don't know why I didn't think that
going back I should have [ __ ] thought
that
but it really does take you interested
did you ever think in your wildest
dreams never be on his show never being
interviewed by him never ever never ever
never so cool dude I'm still just like
I'm just speechless the whole thing
you're gonna have to watch it back with
with Katie and Jace
you're gonna have to I mean you're
you're gonna get you it tomorrow night
you'll be home by when it airs yeah I
will
yeah yeah I'm gonna I'll clip it I'm
gonna clip that one line I got off it's
gonna be it's gonna be while to watch it
with your brother and your fianc I
wonder if they heavily edit it - we'll
see hope hope hope not hope not we'll
see wouldn't be funny for just starts
with him seeing Michelle wolf kill their
baby
maybe we're just nodding giving them
thumbs up to the queer nod and giving
the thumbs up and that's them by the way
that's cool that's it no we're done
there's nothing else it was supposed to
be a whole segment but he's like
Michelle wolf killed her baby we're like
yeah thumbs up and he's like George
Korres is a Nazi
yeah and then it just goes Tim Dylan
comedy been a breeze gots like whoa hold
on slow the roll you know we got to do
now we got a we got to go do brush at
some point Limbaugh is gonna be near
possibly does not have guests know
Collins mmm Collins yeah I could should
imitate him to him ladies and gentlemen
until rush it's rush limbaugh rush Bo
Lamar uh see live live from sunny South
Beach Florida
it's open line Friday
yeah there's no there's no the only one
that's really left to do is Stern yeah
Stern in New York City is the only one
left to do you know I've done no
late-night shows I never had an interest
I had no interest in Colbert Fallon I
think my agent submitted a tape to Conan
four years ago but I've had you know no
interest in doing late-night stand-up
comedy but I really have enjoyed going
on all these major podcasts and and and
and radio shows and internet shows so I
think the only one left to do that I'd
really want to do would be Stern rush I
wouldn't want to do because Rush
find enjoyable even though he's [ __ ]
insane i he's you should be completely
alone just doing his thing
but like I would you know Stern and you
know Stern's the last one because we've
done old I mean what we're gonna do your
mom's house soon that's gonna be in the
book soon and then you know we've done
Joe a bunch we've done Alex I've done
Bennington and I've done you know Jim
and Sam I've done whatever is left of
that whole you know New York kind of
thing I mean I haven't done The
Breakfast Club I guess that would be
cool charlemagne and them I could do
that that's like blacks turn I would
love to see you do some mainstream stuff
though too like Fallon like why didn't
you think about that before we went to
Infowars today well you out of your mind
you [ __ ] on crack I would like to see
you do some mainstream stuff as well now
that we've done Infowars and Alex Jones
has said that he loves our comedy I
think that the next stop would be Fallon
and are you seriously dude or gas leak
in the road what am I gonna do on Fallon
I don't know just antagonize him go nuts
I mean he'll never have me on Seth
Meyers will probably never have me on
it's probably a good idea that they
don't have me on I mean I've talked a
lot of [ __ ] about Fallon my pin tweet is
me saying I think that he bit someone
which isn't true but it's very funny and
I don't know that it isn't true but I
hope it's not true hey you know I mean
I've tweeted The Ellen DeGeneres is in
the CIA and I believe that there's a
decent argument to be made for that that
she's an asset that she's helping you
know I mean you know the only guy that
interacted was Steven paddock the only
guy was shouldn't maybe we should have
asked Jones about paddock or fair oh
yeah
well going back yeah we're going back
and by that I mean tomorrow not kidding
but we're going back because I would
like to I would like to go back we
didn't get a chance to ask him a lot of
things today like affair I was very busy
he was very busy we did the segment but
what was interesting is like I would
like to ask him a lot of things about
but Alan was you only got to interview
the only guy that interacted with
paddock directly Alan and he goes into
his on Alan Alan watch this guy was a
witness
you know the pig would it would is it
one of the biggest mass shootings in
history or the biggest mass shooting in
history and then what is he gonna do go
to Alan and do the boogie what the [ __ ]
is going on have it is don't we have an
interest in having a newsperson
interview this guy to get some kind of
statement on a record and we send them
to Alan so that's the type of thing we
stuck on yeah something's a little weird
there some little weird when Ellen is
the only person that gets to talk to the
one guy he's supposed to go on hannity i
think he cancelled pretty sure he
canceled I think Alan was like the one
thing he actually did that's like just
makes you think just makes you go ahead
but I mean I don't know that I'll get
the opportunity to do any of those
things and it's okay that's okay I'm not
against doing them either but I'm not I
understand why I'm not asked to do them
I'm not I get it I also get why as Snell
doesn't reach out I get why you know I
you know it's disappointing you know I
would like to make a good TV show I'd
like to make a good movie I'd like to
make something really funny I'd like to
answer the milquetoast horseshit safe
comedy with something real and and you
need money to do that and you need
somebody to get behind you to do that
seriously but until then we'll just do
what we're doing on our own and tell
everyone to go [ __ ] themselves you know
with the help of our friends and people
that really like comedy you know but
that's other than that it's like [ __ ] it
you know but it was this was as close to
a black mirror episode black beera
Infowars Ben Avery McMahon Alex Jones
kept calling you Ed McMahon like 20
times called you Ed McMahon 20 times
we're here at Benny where's good Ed
McMahon he started talking about
Caddyshack at some point like for no
reason he went into a few rants where I
didn't know I was just I was on a
rollercoaster I was just trying to ride
it
mmm I was just trying to grab words like
what this that I'm okay and I don't we
didn't get a lot of flack I thought
we're gonna get more
FLAC on your post is anyone mad I mean
no I mean listen I'm not also gonna read
all the comments I've read some of them
and nobody nobody I mean listen I just
don't think I just don't think that uh
you know I just don't think that people
give that much of a [ __ ] hey I think
that we've set up people we've managed
people's expectations to where they
understand that absolutely we're gonna
do something like this yeah you know and
Alex has done a lot of good work and I
mean I know that that's not the most
popular thing to say because he's done
some work that isn't good and didn't
work out well that's also true but I
mean when I mean good work I mean
there's nobody else that got into the
Bohemian Grove and did what he did
there's nobody else had the balls to go
in there and expose that and whatever
that means you could say whatever you
want maybe there's a high end fraternity
maybe it is just the most powerful
people in the world in hoods sacrificing
an effigy of a child which is not a real
thing it's just like whatever it is it's
like a child made of you know sticks or
whatever they burn we're hoping and then
and then this large owl and everything
in any he got that on camera and you can
say whatever you want if you have any
interest in how society works
you can't ignore that right you can't
ignore that
you can't ignore guys in the hoods any
hoods in the woods that's the other
thing that my two little Reid they'll
read that that book that that children's
book dies in the hoods in the woods it's
not about the Klan either it's about the
Bohemian Grove but you can't ignore a
bunch of guys chanting and doing like
pagan rituals in the woods especially
when they own everything it would be one
thing if they owned nothing any but
those are the losers they're so poor
they wear hoods and chant those [ __ ]
guys but when it's like who are those
guys there's like oh they own everything
they own banks and a media company and
they're in the woods sacrificing a fake
child and chanting it's at least curious
you'd at least bring that up right when
you were smoking pot with your buddies
you go let me explain let me ask you
this let me tell you this when you're
eating Taco Bell with your boys and
you're all [ __ ] just still a little
high you go you know what's interesting
I watched a video the other day were the
most powerful people in our country wear
robes go into the woods sacrifice the
effigy of a child or sacrifice a child
in effigy however you say it and they do
it at the base of this large wooden owl
and they chant it's not fun
we don't really hear about that in
school books
isn't that instruments on it's just odd
you would just say it I had a bunch of
skulls kids or whoever from all the
different Ivy League's not all skulls
but like a lot of them even messaged me
when I said in the last podcast message
me if in there Lee thinks they create
some of them created dummy Instagram
accounts some of them were very funny
and clearly not in skullenbones and and
and clearly just some of them were
actually very funny then everything like
that
um what a few of them I thought were
very legit and a lot of them are just
like yeah it's a high level fraternity
where we're trying to create bonds
amongst people you think are gonna be
future leaders which I get nervous know
each other so we're all just trying to
like we go into these hyper personal
situations we all tell each other
everything about ourselves and our
secrets and blah blah blah I get that
like I'm not as weirded out by that I
still think there's it's just the
beginning of creating an elite I get it
I'm not it's not that I'm it's like
that's a very understandable to me I
totally get that but then you look at
like it's still going on when you're in
your 40s 56 he's like you're not college
anymore
there's no homo
fond of being like oh I'm in the coffin
next to you you know they don't even
walk off in front of each other anymore
at the skull bones initiation it's like
that's the fun part that's the real fun
part you know I've met right after I
messaged atom freedom I said you want to
jerk off in a coffin we don't even have
to go to Connecticut I said I could make
that happen so I know your girlfriend
you just had a problem does it matter
leave that communist it doesn't matter
I'll take you to a coffin a treat you're
right
the point is this what is this so that
the sorority secrets of eternity [ __ ] I
kind of get because it's college kids
and they're trying like you know [ __ ]
colleges weird now by the way I'm not
saying that as the great rate contract
listen it's the most powerful fraternity
in the world that's not nothing it's not
enough fun and he's running away and
he's right that Raymond visiting LA by
the way next week yes
la gets fat Raymond very excited we're
taking him the pink wall we're taking
the influencers we're taking the Beverly
Hills Hotel he's just gonna destroy the
city I hope he destroys the entire city
he's just gonna come in and just destroy
the entire city he's gonna throw a lit
cigarette and start the malibu fire okay
Logan's gonna have to be evacuated again
because fat ray is gonna throw a
cigarette and a [ __ ] in a wooded area
but it is [ __ ] a show on the one end
like the skullenbones and that stuff and
and all of those elite groups I I I
think that they that's like a a farm
team for who will eventually be the big
power players and who will eventually do
some probably nefarious things but not
that's not nearly as weird to me as the
Bohemian Grove this is super weird now
it's the same principle right it's the
same principle but the people are a lot
older it's just interesting it's odd and
Alex Jones exposed that and again it's
well worth a watch and it's well worth a
chat about it it's fun to chat to go I
know that everything's about money
eventually I'm not stupid and I know
that everybody wants money and power but
it's very interesting to go what role
does the occult play in this stuff even
just the optics of it like why are
people so married to the optics of the
occult in the ruling class is it a way
to just be edgy right you know cuz it
could be right right like James
elephanta says Instagram account when we
were looking at that it's people just
trying to be edgy maybe right here's the
thing I don't know I I I believe that
there was probably a kernel of truth in
the pizza gate thing that doesn't mean
that the whole thing was true and the
reason I don't think is true or not as
true as people said it was is because
there were no victims
Franklin scandal victims book written
about it grand juries were subpoenaed to
cover it up pizza gate there were no
victims unless you believe that they're
killing [ __ ] everybody right it's on
Epstein again victims hundreds thousands
there there's got to be victims for
these type of things I think to have
credibility cuz they do the Franklin
scandal you know when the Hollywood when
the Hollywood madam was killed Deborah
Jean Paul free who said I'm not suicidal
and then killed herself
there's none of this is but but yes so
when you look at those Pizza gram
Instagram accounts you're like peas gate
Instagram accounts you're like what the
[ __ ] going on because these are weird
accounts she like is either rich people
trying to be edgy which I think they do
because a lot of rich people are just
boring and they haven't really had
normal fulfilling experiences in life so
they try to be edgy and they don't know
how to do it and they you know their
life famously in many cases doesn't have
any snakes so that what they're trying
to do is be dangerous and edgy but I
don't know so when you look at the
occult stuff you go is it that or is
there something a little more sinister a
little darker a little more
superstitious I don't know and I don't
know that I'll ever know I'll only be
able to look at it and glean from it
what I think you know the Hollywood
messaging and all like the music videos
and stuff is it overtly a cult it is
is it trying to brainwash kids in
whatever I don't know I think some of
the people that work in Hollywood are
very sick and god only knows what they
would like to do god only knows what
music videos would look like if Dan
Schneider directed all of them you know
what I mean you just got only knows so I
don't know I don't you know I but I do
think there's a fair amount of that but
I also think a lot of it again it's just
people trying to be edgy trying to be
goth trying to be interesting Billy
Eilish is not that talented she's just
not that good so there's a lot of
distractions from the music because the
music is and I'm not hating on Billy
shoutout to Billy
she's good good for her I'm not hating
on her I think she is talented okay
but again you wouldn't hear Billy Eilish
his voice and lose your mind and go this
is the greatest thing ever right and but
her songs are very catchy and her
brother's very talented writing them and
she does have like a melodic like
whatever like oh whatever but that was
my impression of her I like say whatever
it is because that's result when you
listen lyrics it'll be like all the good
girls suck Satan's [ __ ] and everyone's
like oh so talented but I think so where
does the goth stuff come from there is
it like is she a tool of the elite
establishment - I don't think so I think
they're just compensating for the lack
of voice I think Whitney Houston just
got out there and killed it I think
Eilish is just like yeah it's everything
now it's not just the voices the fashion
and I'm a goth and I'm Nance and I'm
damaged and I'm that and I think that's
more what it is that's my belief from
but again what do what is there somebody
in the background that like has an
interest in this stuff being who knows
but I think from what I've seen a lot of
these people in Hollywood that are just
trying to be goth or edgy or dark or
damaged they're doing it to compensate
for just not being that talented let's
be honest let's call it what it is let's
call it what it is okay you know you're
not Ella Fitzgerald you're not
buddy who is just like [ __ ] Wow goal
is the summer time by Ella Fitzgerald by
the way go listen to something like that
I'd look Janis Joplin at a good version
of summertime that heroin addict Dyke
and then I listened to Ella Fitzgerald
and that the jazz singing the bebop was
so good I you know and I I like Janis
too but so I think that's what it is but
again that doesn't mean that doesn't
mean that there aren't people there that
are into some sick [ __ ] and if they
could Telegraph that sick [ __ ] through
whatever art I'm sure that's also I mean
when you watch Woody Allen movies and
they're all about his relationship with
very young women and then you hear about
that you cannot look at those ago ah I
mean at the very least you go oh okay
yeah I like that part from the Indiana
Jones movie yeah with the the teen girl
or she's like 20 and she's like yeah
Andy you shouldn't have done that to me
I was just a girl
and supposedly George and George Lucas
and Steven Spielberg were arguing about
like what would have happened or
something yeah why yeah why would we
need to make Indiana challenge a
pedophile yeah and we learned that but
also why if you if the goal was to
normalize it why would you make such a
weird reference it was so right I don't
know I mean listen there you could look
at a million things you go what is this
what is that yeah that's when you start
to lose your mind you start talking
about Taylor Swift being in the monarch
cult right you know what was great about
Chris and Yanis being in LA this past
week is we were having dinner with an
executive at ocean Prime yeah and Yanis
goes how many people in Hollywood you
think are actually a pedophile and he's
just cutting into a steak and he goes
I'd say about half yeah well I think the
people in the Golden Globes oh we had
the gold yeah and then because there's
60 million people in California they're
not you know most of them work at
grocery stores but it was funny man that
was so funny than Yonex amigos what the
[ __ ] is going on aren't your enough hot
19 20 year olds for you people like
what's enough is enough already um there
there it's just a [ __ ] why I can't
convey to you people how
how surreal the day was but how it's the
logical conclusion of a lot of the
things we've we've been doing in the
sense that when me and Ben started
becoming friends we wanted to make
ourselves laugh we wanted to explore
areas that most people had the good
sense not to explore most people open
the door they see something they don't
know they open the door cracked ago not
for me we wanted to open the door and
walk fully into it and see what it was
and that's what we've done and probably
hopefully what we'll continue to do and
this was like the culmination of it to
go on that show to see the operation
talk to this guy who we both you know
felt like you kind of knew and had
friends who knew and really to just
climb me as far as we could into that
[ __ ] MacBook I mean which is pretty
scary but you know two years ago we were
watching Infowars
at your house smoking cigarettes in the
garage in the garage laughing because
it's funny mm-hmm and now two years
later we are on the show being
interviewed by this guy and with an open
invite back which will definitely take
it's just a [ __ ] interesting you know
two years it's been a pretty productive
two years you're sober two years this is
like you two you're sober anniversary
yeah with Alex Jones on Infowars if I
make it to midnight yeah you'll yeah
great great question Greg call if Alex
calls us back up and once the house
closes wants us to relapse right now we
absolutely would we drive right to his
studio and start getting [ __ ] we'll
smoke a rock with no stone track with
Alex Jones right now if you wanted us to
absolutely but it will be on the patreon
we'll clip it up we'll throw it on the
patreon Tim de la comédie con for all
the live tour dates that are moving
forward we have a lot of stuff coming up
we hope you guys are grabbing tickets to
it we have even more dates that are
coming up that we're going to announce
me Nick Malin
comas are gonna do something in LA how
cool is that
we have Zanies in Chicago old town
Chicago's one of my favorite rooms
February 5th through the 8th I'm gonna
be there please
get tickets to that that's gonna be a
great [ __ ] show they're selling
pretty quick I think we're almost we're
almost maybe three we were half sold out
a while ago so we're probably home 3/4
of the way sold out you know Ontario
Canada the grandeur theater February
14th and 15th Valentine's Day and if you
like me and you live in Toronto and a
lot of you've messaged me why are you
not going to Toronto I am the Grand
Gerard theatre Ontario Canada 15th and
14 to the month okay New York New York
Caroline's March 12th through the 14th
Caroline's comedy club Bloomington
Minnesota April 9th through the 11th the
house of comedy Phoenix Arizona
May 7th through the 9th I think we just
moved one of those dates to late
February to be part of jfl Northwest so
I'm trying to think what would be
Northwest I'm not sure or maybe we move
the Edmonton date Canada at the comic
strip I don't know
Edmonton we're gonna be Canada's in June
let me tell you what date got moved
right now because I don't want people to
start screaming at me and I know that
you will yeah but I guess that's crazy
I'll eyes I feel bad if you bought
tickets for cap City on Wednesday
they're honoring them Thursday Helium
and Philly Lots request to come here
March 19th through the 21st helium in
Philadelphia make sure that's not skank
fest Penn Google skank fest South in
Houston I don't think it is but March
19th through the 21st Philadelphia
Pennsylvania helium come check that out
if you saw me a year and a half ago I've
got a new hour material you'll enjoy it
skank fest south is March 27th through
the 29th perfect okay good that's
perfectly fine
another thing April 23rd through the
25th we're back in Dallas at high
enos nightclub comedy nightclub we're in
Fort Worth we did the hyenas we're back
in Dallas okay let me tell you another
thing let me just tell you this date
that just got changed because I don't
want you okay here it is House of comedy
okay
we are moving to February 20th and we're
going to be part of jfl Northwest so
that is house of comedy New Westminster
British Columbia I don't even know when
that was supposed that was gonna be
March 5th through the 8th well we've
never even talked about that so well now
we're going to be in British Columbia in
late February we're going to BC House of
comedy in New Westminster British
Columbia there are more dates
Tim Dylan comedy calm has all the dates
all the ticket links Tim Jay Dylan di
llo went on Instagram and Twitter please
leave the podcast a five star review I
mean a positive review and a five star
rating on Apple podcast of course is
available on Spotify subscribe to our
YouTube channel the Tim Dylan show not
my personal dumb channel with nothing on
it go to the Tim Dillon show YouTube
channel subscribed videos coming in the
new year when Ben gets his [ __ ] lazy
act together oh and subscribe to the
YouTube clips channel you subscribe to
YouTube clips channel which is what Tim
Dylan clips yeah Tim Dylan show clips
for Tim Dylan clips yeah so we wanted to
we gotta spell it out for these people
we got a force-feed them like children
like little baby I'm so beat right now I
just want to go to bed but I have to go
to cap City and put on a hell of a show
yeah Tim Dylan show clips Tim Dylan show
clips subscribe to the clips channel the
YouTube channel me Nick Mullen Luis
Gomez will be doing something we
hopefully hopefully the main room of the
Comedy Store a live podcast and a
stand-up show let's see if that comes to
fruition it would be really great if it
does let's see Ben ever you have
anything to say of course go to
patreon.com/scishow
a hundred forty-five archives there a
lot of great episodes and we have like
25 bonus episodes now if you're having
with patreon app you're functionally
[ __ ] it's a bad app tell them what
to do but you're supposed to link the
RSS feed to your podcast player of
choice you're not supposed to use the
app unless you want to engage with
people do not use it to listen to the
show or you can use it on your desktop
it works fine and you can download it
that way but link the custom RSS feed I
have it in the info on the patreon page
and when you sign up it emails you the
link so I don't know what you guys are
doing so I'm yeah yeah yeah stop yelling
I'm yelling for other reasons like
where's the studio you know yell at him
for that yelling for no video yeah yell
at him for that from Ben Avery myself
and all of us at Infowars
there is a war on for your mind and from
our prison planet to yours have a good
day